Oh, I absolutely called the police.
The police were here. I actually know the police
and have a really good report with the police,
because when I was a bartender at the little dive bar
where I met this piece of shit,
the police came in all the time,
and it was, like,
my job to serve them and kind of, like,
like, keep the relationship with them.
So I feel very, very safe in my community.
Very, very safe.
I feel like the police did,
like, three police officers were here in SUVs.
Like, they were looking,
taking pictures, opening the car.
They laughed, they listened to, like,
I told them where they live,
everything. And, like,
I don't have proof of this,
that it's these people. I'm just,
you know, two plus two is four.
The math is mathing. It's making sense of who it is.
Do you know what I mean?
So, no,
I never fucking stay quiet.
I'm never gonna fucking just be like,
oh, no.
The police were called at me to report.
I gave them their names, their number,
their description, their fucking everything.
Told them where to find the car.
And the police went looking.
They're like, oh,
we didn't find the car. And then I'm like,
well, I bet you the car is there now,
and the car was it. So we're on it.
The police were back talking to my neighbors.
Like, it's not like I just take the shit laying Down!
I just want the whole entire world to see
what happens when alpha men get mad.
They're so big and strong until a girl stands up to them
and then they're all of a sudden a little bitch
and got a resort to bullying.
And it needs to be highlighted
in the same way
that Tom Brady and Rob Gronkowski are just making fucking jokes,
that 72 year old Bill Belichick is shacking up with a 24 year old.
Her brain isn't even fully developed.
She is literally practically a fucking child
and they just make jokes about it.
This is what women have to stand up for. Women!
Women have to say what the fuck is going on?
And this is how these fucking men treat women!